all right i'm going to talk about more
loki you know what i like about loki
he's constantly learning he's constantly
developing new skills and speaking of
which i want to thank the sponsor of
this video this video is brought to you
by skillshare
nailed it skillshare is an online
learning community where millions come
together to take that next step in their
creative journey creative endeavors like
illustration graphic design photography
animation creative writing film and
video
much more speaking of film and video
they have a class called learn premiere
pro and edit a how-to guide for
beginners as someone who's always used
premiere pro for my videos and
had to self-teach myself yeah that would
have been a welcome class if it was
so accessible back then so you take that
class you have to jump on me as always
skillshare is curated for learning which
means you're not bogged down with ads
just a creative world
and atmosphere and annual subscriptions
less than ten dollars a month and the
first 1 000 of my subscribers to click
the link below will get a free premium
trial membership so click the link below
and get on that creative process that
calls to you and thank you once again to
skillshare for sponsoring this video
i do appreciate it right now we're going
to talk about loki episode 2 couple
things to remember uh one
spoiler warning i get spoilerish when i
talk about episodes of shows
only way i know how to do it and two
it's not a play-by-play i'm not going to
talk about everything in this episode
just some things that stood out to me
some things that the episode made me
think about as much as i want to talk
about the fact that though they fought
in an electronic store i feel like there
are more
interesting things to talk about though
that electronic store was in the year
2050 and
that was pretty modern tech to us that
was some pretty 2021 tech that i saw
in that electronics store was so was
that a retro electronics store
i don't know i do appreciate the
optimism of this show it's like oh
this show thinks we're going to be
around in 2050. that's sweet so in this
episode of loki loki gets the brilliant
idea that
well this alternate loki is hanging out
in apocalypse settings you know it's
because you can't do anything in a
timeline
without vastly affecting and creating a
variance
timeline that now needs to be eliminated
things need to be controlled these three
super deities out there big control
freaks gods i tell you but i like how
they test the hypothesis like right when
they arrived i was like where are they
oh big volcano in the background big
this is pompeii i really like that about
this episode i was like yeah
you have a hypothesis now you need to
test it
science so they go to pompei and loki's
tell everyone like you're gonna die and
he
releases goats like oh and wilson was
like let's just make small
that's not how loki worked loki's all
the end is nigh release the goats
and then the volcano happens and there's
no variant whatsoever
there's no alternate timeline so that's
where alternate loki's hanging out in
these apocalypse settings doesn't have
to be world breaking or world ending
just a civilization or an event
where nobody gets out of there alive
nobody lives to tell the tale
what you say and do there i guess it
doesn't matter all right so the thing
that got loki thinking about this was
ragnarok he was like yeah i could go to
ragnarok do and say anything
and asgard gets destroyed which means
what i said and did
didn't matter which means there would be
no time variant timeline which means i
could do that which means that's what
alternate loki's
doing true clever but it's not perfect
right i mean
all right bear with me on this thought
experiment right thought experiments are
fun so here it goes let's say loki does
that let's say he goes to asgard right
before ragnarok everyone's gonna die
you're all gonna die your toast let's
say one person's like i kind of believe
him
all right so he just takes a bunch of
food and runs down rainbow road to try
to get to the bifrost to get the [ __ ]
out of dodge uh while running down
rainbow road he drops a banana or
another asgardian slippery fruit they
gotta have one so at that point that guy
when he's running down rainbow road
could
fall slip smack his head die spiked blue
shell can smack him always happens on
rainbow road because of the big fight at
the end of thor ragnarok when hulk is
running to get out of asgard
he slips on the banana peel falls off
the rainbow
road does not make it off of asgard gets
destroyed in asgard as asgard gets
destroyed thus no one's around to snap
and bring everyone back thus
thanos wins because of a banana i mean
it's not likely but it's possible and
there was a conversation in this episode
that may be like
huh really because when owen wilson's
character and loki they're talking
loki's like what's the end game like
what's the
goal of the timeline men in black here
like what are you guys doing and owen
wilson says
you get to the point where there's no
chaos only order till the end of time i
was like
really well sounds an awful lot like a
dictatorship to me i mean it does sound
like i've heard that conversation that
speech before
i was like it sounds an awful lot like
you're saying i'm on mission
what mission peace in our time
which is the rationale of every dictator
in the history of dictators since the
dawn of dictators
that's what they think that's how they
think then you have these
three gods who created timelines wiping
out
timelines because they feel it's best
for existence i mean when owen wilson's
character and loki they were talking and
owen wilson's like i mean
listen to yourself you know you're a god
you're from asgard
magic and all that and loki's like
that's different he's like no his eyes
exactly the same but if it's comparable
if it's the same
for a long time that we've known loki
loki's been
a dick his wants are for what's best for
him not what's best for the masses so
if these gods are comparable to that
concept who's to say that they're
best for people for civilizations i mean
chaos is that which
brings life right like chaos is life you
can't have
life flourish without chaos at the
biological level every genetic mutation
of chance that helped life
spring forward leap forward helped life
flourish
it wouldn't happen without chaos they
might just want timelines to conform to
what's best for them
not what's best for existence it's
possible lady loki might have figured
this out and maybe that's what she's
fighting possible that she might be
trying to
free civilizations from the influence of
these fatalistic deity dicks which is an
awesome concept i don't know if they're
gonna go there but it's interesting it's
an interesting thought we've hit
peak fire emblem three houses and loki
you haven't played that game
play it and that was a big reveal this
episode is that alternate loki
is actually lady loki something that the
internet was like
yeah it's totally gonna be lady loki
like people in the know i personally
know nothing about lady loki other than
that was an
alternate loki costume in marvel heroes
man i miss marvel heroes so many hours
midtown monday but i enjoyed this
episode it got me in my head thinking
about chaos theory and whether or not
going to an apocalypse setting is
actually a fail-safe way of not creating
variant timelines but more than that
this is when i started humoring this
organization the tva
is whether or not they're actually good
it sounds like these three
deity figures which might not even exist
i don't know
it might just be a legend that's passed
down and people are actually serving
nothing and it looks like these three
time gods
and the tva or both are trying to
control free will
and reality so much to the point where
now henceforth they will be known
as twitter alright so episode 2 of loki
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see
[Music]
more
you